what's this one now the dance of dragons
a true telling by Grand M monin well
that sounds like a proper story what's
it about it's the story of the fight
between rera tarar and her half by The
Regan for control of the Seven
Kingdoms both of them thought they
belonged on the Iron Throne when people
started declaring for one of them or the
other their fight divided the kingdoms
in to Brothers fought Brothers dragons F
dragons by the time it was over
thousands were
dead and it was a disaster for the
tarian as well they never truly
recovered the dance of
dragons why is that a
dance it's just what they call it make
much sense I think it's
[Music]
poetic rira Targaryen was murdered by
her brother or or rather his Dragon it
ate her while her son
watched if you'd had to
choose between reira and
Egon who would you have
chosen who wouldn't have chosen
either saw the choosing sides that made
everything so horrible sometimes a
person has to choose
2 years until season 2 is a long period
but you can still stay in the house of
the Dragon World by listening to Fire
and Blood audio book for free house of
the Dragon is based on Fire and Blood
book and covers the entire targaryan
history starting from aegon the
Conqueror and his Conquest as well as
Meer the cruel and other legendary
targaryens including the current and
future events of House of the Dragon go
and listen to it for free with aable
trial using our link in the
description